these days you have a wide choice of
mobile devices you can take with you to
check your email bug your friends on
Facebook take funny pictures watch video
and stream music unfortunately though
we've also added an error where the days
of unlimited data they're just gone so
we're going to talk to you today about
some ways you can check your mobile data
usage so you don't get charged up the
yin-yang or have your carrier's slow
down your data to like a very tiny crawl
the four major carriers all have ways
for you to check your data usage and
there's easy ways than there's more
involved ways so let's start with the
easy way with AT&T you pick up your
phone and you go dial star data pound
and you'll go through you'll get this
little robot voice and the robot will
tell you she's going to send you a text
and that text will tell you how many
texts you've sent and how much data
you've used look verizon it's a little
different you press star data and you
will also get a text in just a couple
minutes telling you how much data you've
used sprint's is star for and then
you'll get a menu you need to press for
again and you'll also get an update
their via text with t-mobile you can't
actually dial a number but we're going
to go through some other ways that you
can you can check this so if you've got
one of those Apple devices you can go
and download a couple apps from the App
Store so for instance there's the
official AT&T 10 G download for free but
it tends to be bugging crashes a little
bit if you don't mind spending a couple
of dollars you can go for a better
version called data man which is fun
because it also can send you some alert
so you can tell it to warn you when you
start getting close there's also a
verizon wonder if you have the iphone on
verizon
up here on Android you also have some
other choices you can go and get the my
verizon the my AT&T or the my t mobile
apps and those will also tell you how
much data be used and that's easier than
you know dialing the little numbers
there are some tools out there that can
actually help you reduce the amount of
data you're using without you actually
having to change what you do on your
device one of these is called onavo
which is a free app for the iphone or
the ipad and you installed on your on
your device and it compresses the data
that's being sent to and from your your
device so that you reduce the amount of
data that's actually being sent that can
help keep you under your limit
unfortunately however right now it
doesn't compress video which is actually
the biggest user of data on your device
the other tool which you can use both on
iOS and on android is the opera mini
browser and opera does much the same
thing that onavo does where it
compresses the data that's being sent to
and from your device so when you're
looking at web pages they shrink down
the images so you're not loading the big
images so how much data you get depends
on which care you have and what plan you
have but a lot of them these days are
close to two gigabytes so for a lot of
people they don't actually even know
what two gigabytes means in terms of
bandwidth on a mobile phone if you're
watching video that gets you about 10 to
13 hours of video in terms of emails
it'll get you more emails and you can
count text messages you could text
message be without stopping for the
entire month and you'd never go over two
gigabytes so you the thing to watch here
watch how much video you're using and
watch how much radio you're streaming
you